мільйони доларів то євро юшку kitty за
доповідала чиновники середнього рангу
судді депутати
про прем'єра гройсмана та мільйона хоч
позовних доларів записаних на дружину
опозиціонерка ти машинку за видами і
питання заначку скільки сотень тисяч
доларів їй людини на ви не тільки і
президент порошенка вин володіє
спадкоємство ми офшорами хоч хоч і
фкіс це клару вов вино країна багата
між ним європейські експерти до
бути на прилюдно не гігантські
статуї українських політиків чи то пак
служба fcew з покину але взявши це було
силома че кованим я особи стогони навіть
добре на там ще й так одразу дрібницям у
українці були якісь якщо та й ту саму
розбагатіла на тому, що клала державний
Лікар своїх каша не мій регулярно
бачимо за українським відвідувачем ху
кидали
олігархи всі носять води на каті але і
майже під мільйон євро це їй явно не і
проясни багатство теж не для кого брюса
Чи великим сюрпризом ціни стало модним і
спить сумки у декларування моя стата
розморожування в край важливий рік для
україни кредити мвф
ще один сонячний політичний ефект
можна його за право дружині безвізового
режиму з ес
цар відкриття з результатом європейських
зис і там ще яєць навіть ти знову на
україну сюди боротьбі з епідемією
корупція саккра провального прямо як
ну а всередині що політичний ефект
декларування більше часті на або
thymus це моя ви правда ось і вся за
гігантські суми увы канав че за канада
вч це судно бачив як влади електронної
декларації кардинально змінить правила
ігри в український політик 7 граматики з
оцінюватиму і політики де значно
велику не дозуємо видуватимуть
себе акції проти кремів політики йому
повернися нових виборів до парламенту
зав'язку з декларації про інсульт зросла у
час даня до кайрат сили США перший
коло взводом треба буде зис уват і
сувої впали таким чиновники в обоз
здивуйте крихти нога кінь європе і
розслідування вказують експерти мають
почитай вікна з США